i need you to tell me if you can
understand what
word or words the possible
next president is trying to utter i'll
need an effective strategy to mobilize
true international effort to pressure
i'll lead an effective strategy
to mobilize trello
i listen to this quote i've probably
listened to it now 50 times
i think at least some of what he's
saying is true
true something international pressure
can we play that again can we go back to
that other true nala
i'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true
international pressure so there are too
many syllables obviously in there but i
think what he's trying to get it is true
international pressure but i don't think
he's going to mobilize true
international pressure
i don't think that anybody is going to
pay him any heat at all
because his brain is putting i know it's
sort of sad to say that
but the man is past his sell-by date
folks and so when you vote for him
i can't feel too sometimes i say oh i
feel bad for joe i don't feel bad for
joe i don't feel bad for guys who sue
nuns
because they won't pay for abortions i
don't feel bad for that i don't i don't
feel bad for guys who have lied through
their teeth for 50 years in government
and who have engaged in corrupt deals in
ukraine and china apparently
i don't feel bad for guys who may become
the president of the united states
i think we shouldn't feel bad for that
guy at all i think we should feel bad
for us if he gets elected
because that guy's not even gonna be the
president that guy is gonna go
he's gonna lie in bed and play tetris
all day
and either kamala harris are more likely
that bureaucracy is going to take over
maybe it was just a gaff maybe it's just
his childhood stutter that disappeared
for 60 years but then
somehow came back all of a sudden and we
have to pretend that it's a childhood
stutter when it's obviously not it's
obviously
decline well we got another one of these
examples
uh again this one i i don't think
there's any chance we're going to figure
it out
but but joe biden is very focused on the
importance of
under barack and me it also holds pluto
i'll
call polluters accountable with the most
ambitious environmental justice agenda
ever
okay so there you do get at least the
one word which is
polluters he is he is saying polluters
there but there are all these extra
syllables all around and then everything
slurs at the back end of this
joe biden is obviously exhausted these
incidents have gotten worse by the end
of the campaign than they were at the
beginning now
don't forget it for much of the campaign
joe biden has been hiding in his
basement
so you haven't gotten to see many of
these why did the biden campaign choose
to hide him in his basement they used
coronavirus as an excuse
but that obviously was simply an excuse
because they didn't want these moments
because they have seen him and they
interact with him
and they know that the man is obviously
in cognitive decline and he doesn't have
any stamina
i get it campaigns are really exhausting
i've been on a lot of campaigns
and i've been on campaign since i was 19
years old and even when i was 19 years
old i was exhausted doing them because
you're working 20 hours a day for 18
months at a time
so i get it but if you get
tired from doing a modest number of
campaign events like joe biden is doing
how on earth are you going to stand up
to the pressures of being president you
can't do it
it is not possible and he won't
even if and i hope it doesn't happen but
even if he does get elected president
joe biden is not going to be a
particularly hands-on president
other people are going to do the job for
him
and unfortunately the the establishment
that that
he is empowering the groups that he is
empowering are socialists
radicals people who don't want equality
of opportunity
they want equality of outcome they will
go in they will take your money they
will redistribute it
they will institute a new american caste
system
that discriminates on the basis of race
and sex they are already doing that
and they are explicitly promising to do
it
that's what you're going to get with joe
biden
and some people are endorsing him
somehow i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts